new and powerful video tonight showing
the moments law enforcement shot a man
at red rock this was the first of three
police shootings in the last week we
take you through this intense encounter
in the early morning hours of veterans
day
nhp has released body cam video from a
police shooting at red rock conservation
area the morning of veterans day the
mother of the suspect 29 year old eric
lagreed told police her son was going to
shoot himself or drive head on into
upcoming traffic in his black toyota
tacoma
this is the moment nhp had located and
blocked in lagreed don't do it lagreed
used his pickup truck to ram a park
ranger and an nhp vehicle before taking
off
a trooper caught and collided with
lagreed's truck
lagreed refused to get out of the car
and kept accelerating
the suspect was shot in both legs
somebody get up
lagreed faces multiple charges including
battery of a protected person resisting
a public officer and damaging or
destroying state property no officers
were injured during the shooting